so we are now really getting down to the
core of the argument that is becoming
the argument for Donald Trump and for
the people that back him up and many
Republicans which is we've got to open
up the economy soon we've got to stop
the physical distancing in a lot of
places we've got a reopen business and
for lack of a better term this is what
dr. Anthony foul he calls letting it rip
when when this was mentioned a week ago
or so feels like months ago
pouchy referred to ending all of the
provisions and distancing and just
letting the virus do what it's going to
do he referred to it as letting it rip
more people will get the virus more
people will die but the economy or
really what is in Trump's mind is the
stock market right but he's talking
about the economy it might improve but a
lot more people are going to die so
fundamentally when you boil this down
especially when you look at who is is
mostly dying from the virus the question
is how many grandmas someone's grandmas
how many of them are worth allowing to
die in order to save the stock market
it's about older folks dying mostly
older folks to save Wall Street and the
stock market what is each life worth to
different people is essentially the
question here how much economic downturn
is justified based on how many
additional people will likely die if we
stop distancing and we reopen stuff for
days now Trump and people around him
have expressed an interest in ramping
back up because they don't want the Cure
to be worse than the disease as Donald
Trump and Larry Kudlow and others have
started to say yesterday Donald Trump
tweeted quote our people want to return
to work they will practice social
distancing and all else and seniors will
be watched over protectively and
lovingly we can do two things together
the Cure cannot be worse by far than the
problem Congress must act now we will
come back strong then yesterday during a
Fox News townhall Trump floated for the
first time a specific date which is
Easter Easter Sunday April 12 have to do
that I'd love to have it open by Easter
okay I would love to have it open by you
sir I will I will tell you that right
now I would love to have that it's such
an important day for other reasons but
I'll make it an important day for this
too I would love to have the country
opened up and just raring to go
by Easter now this is insanely soon to
even be thinking about this now if you
put a gun to my head and you say Trump
is deterrent Trump's doing this on April
12th no matter what how would you
suggest that it be done in that scenario
if I were Trump I would say listen I
want to do this on April 12th but in
order to do it I need your help
I need all 50 governors not 18 plus two
more doing partial stuff I need all 50
governors to shut down stay at home
order shelter in place until April 12th
everybody's got to do it because
remember 30 states aren't doing a damn
thing yet
if Trump did that then maybe you could
partially reopen on April 12th outside
of hot spots with older folks still
staying home and again this is like if
you put a gun to my head and you say
Trump's doing it April 12th how would
you say he does it but this reminded me
of a video of a young guy who confronts
economist Milton Friedman decades ago on
this issue of what's a life worth how
much should we spend or fail to earn
forgo in earnings in exchange for each
life it's a very utilitarian argument
almost psychopathically so so let's look
at this here's a guy asking Milton
Friedman about the Ford Pinto the Ford
Pinto is a vehicle that was very poorly
designed many deadly fires related to
gas tanks that ruptured during accidents
and Ford knew about it and they could
have prevented it with a 13 dollar part
on each car let's look at this video
clip Apple I have just one more this has
to do with the the Ford Pinto I'm not
sure if you're aware of recent
revelations that have come out about the
production of that car Ford produced it
knowing full well that in any rear-end
collision the gas tank would blow up
because they had failed to install $13
plastic block
in front of the gas tank and ford
estimated in an internal memo that that
would cost about 200 lives a year and
they estimated further that the cost of
each life would be two hundred thousand
dollars they multiplied and they found
that the cost of installing those blocks
in each of the cars would be more than
the cost of saving those two hundred
lives and over the past seven years the
car has been produced and over a
thousand lives have been lost
seems to me that Ford did what would be
the right thing according to your policy
and yet that seems to me to be very
wrong so the kid lays it out there and
here is how Milton Friedman responds
which is essentially the calculation
that Trump and others are now starting
to make a very utilitarian calculation
well let me ask you let's suppose it
would have cost a billion dollars per
person should for to put them in a none
the less the print you're not arguing
about principle your no no no because
return not nobody can take the principle
nobody can accept the principle that
that an infinite value should be put on
an individual life because in order to
get the money involved in order to get
the resources involved it's not money in
order to get the resort they have to
come from someone so the kit says this
cheap part could have prevented all of
these deaths and Friedman says well at
what point would it not be logical for
Ford to spend the money like in other
words if it wasn't thirteen dollars per
car but if it was a million dollars per
car do you still force Ford to fix the
car at a million dollars per car and the
conversation continues and here we are
skipping ahead a little bit right you're
not arguing anything about principle
you're just asked to you're just arguing
whether Ford used two hundred thousand
dollars was the right number or not no
I'm not I suppose that was harder
million dollars No
those that were 200 million dollars what
should Ford have done 200 million
dollars for what suppose it would have
cost two hundred million dollars her
life saved
should Ford still have spent that 200
million dollars you mean that's not
really the question yes it is a question
yes the question that's the only
principle involved I don't know whether
Ford did the right came to the right
answer or not what's the question of
whether these numbers are valid numbers
for the relative cost of different
things so this kid wants to focus on the
question which is here we know $13 per
car would have prevented all of this
death Milton Friedman says what's the
principal though where is the line where
we say this level of expense to save a
life make sense this level of expense to
save a life does not and unfortunately
this entire framing is logically
fallacious and it's what Republicans and
Trump are doing how many additional
lives do we lose if we reopen the
economy versus the economic cost are
they mostly older people are they mostly
younger people how much is the life of
an 80 year old worth in economic terms
versus the life of a 20 year old with
many work years ahead of them and that's
the implicit question but it's not this
simple the question of what is a life
worth to the economy is a very different
than question then are we willing to
essentially sacrifice people in their
lives because on some calculation made
in Washington DC or to wherever Donald
Trump is doing these meetings it's worth
more to the economy but the reality is
the argument Friedman makes is a
fallacious argument very often
economists whose views are those of
Milton Friedman will take these
situations to infinity to be able to
defeat them the reality is that this is
never the case
think about the Ford's situation the
idea of if it was to cost Ford a million
dollars per car to fix the Pinto should
they still do it it's bogus because the
Pinto costs thirty five hundred dollars
at the time that's the retail cost back
in the 70s if the cost to fix the Pinto
was a million dollars they wouldn't
print
the car and that's why we shouldn't fall
for these to infinity nonsense arguments
the kid isn't arguing human life has an
infinite value the kids arguing the life
has a value that is more than the 13
dollars that it would cost Ford to fix
the Pinto in the same way
Trump is calculating that grandma's life
is not worth what he believes the
economy will lose if he keeps the
economy closed and people are bringing
this to infinity it's not viable that we
can't do this forever and we can't do it
period a to infinity but what we're
talking about is a temporary economic
slowdown to save so many people the
curves are the difference between a few
thousand Dying tens of thousands
hundreds of thousands and millions of
people this is one of the oldest
economic arguments the pushing to
infinity Trump is quickly getting his
way on this and a lot of people are
going to die now I hope you're staying
home and if you are and if you're
looking for something to do tonight 8:00
p.m. Eastern is the David Pakman show
viewer chess tournament I am the 2019
champion because we had one game I beep
at at the end of 2019 we now have a
proper chess tournament we'll be playing
tonight follow me on social media for
info I'll be streaming 8 p.m. tonight
join us don't miss it I'd love it if you
checked out a YouTube channel we're
partnering with their content is great
and they're good friends of the David
Pakman show the channel is called up
flip and you can get there at david
pakman.com slash up flip make sure you
subscribe when you're there if you own
your own business if you're thinking of
starting one if you're interested in
entrepreneurship and building companies
as many of you know I am I think you
will love this because every week up
flip gives you sort of an inside look at
a successful small business how did the
entrepreneur do it how was it built from
the ground up the stories are inspiring
I always love learning about how
business owners got to where they are
and they share a ton of wisdom about
mistakes what they learned really great
insights and up flip up loads new videos
every Wednesday featuring a totally new
business check it out at david
pakman.com
up flip link is right down below
underneath this video subscribe to their
channel and click that Bell icon to get
notifications